البدايه من مقال في صحيفتها اريتس بقلم
اندرس بيرسن الخبير المتخصص في العلاقات
بين الاتحاد الاوروبي واسرائيل وفلسطين
يقول فيه ان من الصعب اليوم رؤيه طريق
واضح لتحقيق نصر عسكري حاسم لاسرائيل في
غزه وقد تضطر مره اخرى الى التعامل مع وقف
رسمي او غير رسمي لاطلاق النار وهذا يعني
ان الساسه الاسرائيليين كان مخطئين عندما
وعدوا مرارا وتكرارا بعد حرب عام
2014 بان الحرب القادمه في غزه ستكون
الاخيره جورسليم بوست با افتتاحيتها انه
يجب على رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو كبح جماح وزراء حكومته بطريقه
اكثر قوه وتضيف ان بعض اعضاء الحكومه
مهتمون اكثر بزرع بذور الشقاق كما انه هم
انحرفوا عن مسار مهامهم بدلا من التركيز
بشكل مسؤول على الجهود الحربيه في
[موسيقى]
البلاد اشارت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الى ان
القلق في واشنطن الان لا يتعلق بشن هجوم
على اسرائيل بقدر ما يتعلق بشن هجوم
اسرائيلي على حزب الله وقد ابلغت الولايات
المتحده اسرائيل انه اذا تحرك حزب الله
عبر الحدود فان واشنطن ستدعم اسرائيل
ولكن ليس العكس ويقول خبراء انهم لا يرون
اهتماما كبيرا بتصعيد ايران في هذه
المرحله لانها تحقق معظم مصالحها دون
ذلك نشرت مجله ناشنال انتر مقالا قالت فيه
ان على الشعب اللبناني ان يستعد لان الرد
من حزب الله امر لا مفر منه فقد تجاوزت
اسرائيل خط قواعد الاشتباك القديمه واذا
لم يرد حزب الله فسيبدو مترددا ومسلما
للخوف في عيون العدو ومع ذلك فان فرصه
تحول الانتقام الى حرب واسعه النطاق مثل
حرب غزه لا تزال
ضئيله نفتت صحيفه ذا جارديان الى ان
مجموعه من المتدربين السابقين في البيت
الابيض وقعوا رساله يحثون فيها الرئيس جو
بايدن على دعم وقف فوري لاطلاق النار في
غزه واتهموه بانه نكث وعده بالسعي لتحقيق
المساواه والعداله بدعمه القصف الاسرائيلي
على القطاع واشار هؤلاء المتدربون الى ان
العالم يشهد تناقض بين القيم التي اعتنقها
معا والافعال التي تتم
حاليا الكاتب مارك لينت قال في مقال بمجله
فورين افاز ان الصين تستغل حرب اسرائيل في
غزه لكسب دول الجنوب وتلجا بيجين الى
الترويج ان العالم اصبح اكثر فوضويه من اي
وقت مضى كما تقدم الصين نفسها باعتبارها
رائده عالم متعدد الحضارات وشريكه في
التنميه والسياده وانها لا تجبر الدول
الاخرى على اختيار احد الجانبين في عالم
يشهد انقساما
[موسيقى]
حادا